it seems like Nintendo actually listened
to our prayers because the SNES classic
edition is finally coming and it's
packed with so many incredible games
from Super Mario World 2 Link to the
Past to earthbound it's really hard to
complain about the lineup with that
being said here are six games a few of
the GameSpot editors wish the NES
classic had if your favorite game is on
the list put it in the comments below
and consider subscribing for more videos
like this one
although the IP is all but dead
actraiser is a piece of gaming history
that truly represents the experimental
innovation that occurred and the SNES is
hey day while there were plenty of
action platformers and a surprising
number of top-down strategy games
actraiser was the only one that
definitely combined the two genres and
it featured a framed story that
positioned you as the creator and
protector of the world who needed to
appease his followers in order to gain
more power actraiser did get a sequel
three years later though it is skewed
the strategy element entirely and
outside of releases on the Virtual
Console and mobile the entire franchise
has lain dormant but this quirky
mishmash deserved a spot on the SNES
classic pilotwings isn't a Nintendo
property that gets a lot of love these
days but when the SNES debuted the
original pilotwings was an impressive
game that offered a lot of variety in a
single package under the guise of
earning various pilots licenses you were
thrust into the cockpits of planes into
the harness of a skydiving parachute and
even buckled into a jetpack each
scenario presents of unique controls and
objectives but it was the intuitive and
thoughtful controls that made the
experience a pleasure even when you fail
repeatedly while perfecting your
piloting techniques a game about
learning how to pilot various
contraptions doesn't sound exciting but
the use of the NES is mode 7 feature
gave pilot wings environments a sense of
depth that was unparalleled and console
gaming at the time it was easy to
respect the work pile of wings did to
differentiate the Super Nintendo from
the competition and it's disappointing
to hear that it won't be a part of the
SNES classic
Earthworm Jim may not be as iconic as
Mario and Sonic but the game he hails
from combined platforming and 2d gunplay
in a fun and uniquely bizarre package
the premise is that a spacesuit crash
lands onto earth and gives a normal
earthworm superhuman strength earthworm
jim used a cool art style coupled with
excellent hand-drawn animations visually
the game has aged relatively well it
also featured some crazy batch levels
that brought you to a planet made of
mucus and a stage where you're
navigating your way through intestines
the gunplay allows you to shoot in eight
different directions and the platforming
allows you to jump and swing from ledge
to ledge using your earthworm head as
the lasso the game spawned three sequels
and a children's cartoon show and
deserves to be played if you're a fan of
90s style platformers while the NES
classic edition included Tecmo Bowl the
SNES classic leaves out its platform's
most iconic sports game NBA Jam it's a
game that was just plain old-fashioned
fun two-on-two basketball where players
catch on fire when they're doing well
knock each other down to steal the ball
and generally ignore NBA rules making
for an incredibly entertaining
experience the basketball games appeal
extended even to non basketball fans its
arcade style gameplay is approachable
and doesn't require in-depth knowledge
of the real world sport add in the
over-the-top commentary and multiplayer
friendly nature of the game an NBA Jam
was seemingly tailor-made for inclusion
as an SNES classic release
the SNES was one of many consoles that
brought an arcade experience to the
living room but SNES games like super
r-type had selling points beyond its
similarities to their arcade
counterparts part port part remix super
r-type took four stages from r-type to
and introduced three new areas much of
super are types appeal is how well it
retains the original games engaging
weapon system some weapon pickups are
more useful than others in specific
situations and environments and one way
of mastering an R type game is knowing
when to use a specific armament and
where to obtain it this also speaks to
super are types high difficulty which
would have complemented the equally
challenging super ghouls and ghosts a
game that has been confirmed for the
SNES classic the Super Nintendo is home
to many beloved RPGs including the
charmingly odd earthbound and of course
Final Fantasy 6 both of which enjoy a
spot on the list of games bundled in the
SNES classic while I can't really point
a finger at Nintendo for ignoring RPGs I
can at least begrudge that Chrono
Trigger won't be coming along for the
ride Chrono Trigger is regarded by many
to be one of the best console RPGs ever
made it comprised an unusual time-travel
mechanic had a complex combat system
that allowed you to strategically
combine character abilities and had a
really memorable soundtrack
[Music]
and all of these are valid reasons to
continue playing the game today 22 years
after its release Chrono Trigger also
represents an interesting crossroads for
square in Enix years before the two
companies merged Chrono Trigger was
devised by the leaders of two competing
RPG behemoths Yuji Horii of Dragon Quest
and Hironobu Sakaguchi of Final Fantasy
and had additional input from the
creator of Dragon Ball Z Akira Toriyama
an interesting touchstone in an
all-around lovely game Chrono Trigger
absolutely deserves a spot in the SNES
classic editions library
[Music]
you